I am about to get buried in concrete and
while that's happening I'm going to
explain everything you need to know
about this substance
so the first thing that I want to clear
up is the difference between cement and
concrete because people often mix these
up okay cement is like the glue it's the
Matrix of stuff oh there I feel it okay
that feels good now concrete is cement
plus aggregate so plus gravel and sand
and this is filling up really rather
quickly cement is the most important
man-made substance on the planet we use
more of it than any other substance
apart from water every year 500
kilograms of cement are created for
every man woman and child on Earth and
that amount of cement can make two cubic
meters of concrete which is about two of
these big fish bowls
this video is sponsored by Ren
I don't think people realize just how
important concrete is so here's another
way to think about it every year we make
a certain weight of goods out of copper
more out of aluminum and then you have
glass asphalt lime iron is a big one for
all the steel and then there's ceramic
and wood but by far the solid product we
make the most of is cementitious
material essentially cement we use as
much of it as we do all other materials
combined and it's easy to see why
concrete is liquid rock you can pour it
into any shape you like it's strong and
durable and inexpensive and it is so
easy to produce that people have been
making a version of it for thousands of
years
to make primitive cement the key
ingredient is limestone which is
basically calcium carbonate if you heat
it up to around a thousand degrees
Celsius that drives off CO2 out of the
rock leaving calcium oxide which is also
known as quick lime now if you grind up
the calcium oxide and mix it with water
you get an exothermic reaction that
creates calcium hydroxide which you can
pour into a mold and over a time it will
absorb CO2 from the atmosphere turning
back into calcium carbonate as the water
evaporates
now that's a pretty good primitive
cement it's the first way that people
ever made cement but there are several
drawbacks to it I mean for one thing you
can't make the molds very big because
otherwise CO2 can't penetrate all of the
material and Harden it plus it's not
going to work underwater where there is
no CO2 to harden your mixture
the Romans discovered the solution to
these problems they added volcanic ash
called pozalana to the crushed Limestone
before heating it up and they discovered
this cement was much stronger and much
more durable they used it to create the
largest unreinforced concrete dome in
the world the pantheon which has stood
for 2 000 years and they built concrete
Piers into the sea which hardened
underwater some of which are still
standing today
I did not expect it to feel this heavy
like it's already like really weighing
down my feet and making me slightly
concerned about being able to get out
what I can tell you is that concrete is
about three times as dense as water
yeah okay I'm gonna try to lift a leg
just to see how bad it's going to be
what I like is having my feet on the
bottom and I'm not sure I can get them
back down there after I lift it up but
oh boy okay so that was like I'm gonna
try to lifting this leg pretty slowly
and I was able to lift it
so at least up to this point I am able
to get out my fear is that the concrete
is so dense that when it gets up around
my chest it may apply a lot of pressure
making it hard to breathe it's like
being in a trench and having a cave in
on you you get in your lungs so you can
breathe because once they contract and
the weight gets against your lungs
that's gonna be hard have you thought
about that well now that you mention it
but we do have oxygen on hand just in
case earlier I practiced how I could get
out of the bowl if I'm in trouble you
feel
no problems
so how did Roman concrete Harden
underwater and in thick slabs that CO2
couldn't possibly penetrate
there is a claim that it was Superior to
Modern concrete so was it
for centuries the Roman recipe was lost
it was only discovered in a book in a
Swiss Monastery in the 1400s and since
then Architects scientists and Engineers
have been experimenting with different
cement recipes to try to achieve the
best result now it turns out that that
Incredible strength durability and
ability to set underwater of the Roman
cement that came from the pozalena that
volcanic ash that was added and nearly 2
000 years later people discovered that
adding clay or Shale to the Limestone
before it was crushed and heated
produced the same effect and the reason
is that all of these materials contain
silica and silica totally changes the
chemistry of the cement it means that it
doesn't need to dry in order to harden
in fact the water becomes an integral
part of that hardened concrete so that
it actually achieves maximum strength
when it sets underwater
so this is the compressive cylinder
curing room we're required to maintain
the concrete samples and 100 humidity so
we've chose to submerge them in water in
a lime bath every time concrete
suppliers pour concrete on a job site
they cast sample cylinders of the
material so they can later test it to
ensure it has the strength required so
we actually intercept a little bit of
the concrete going into whatever
structure they're pouring a slab a wall
will intercept it into a wheelbarrow
take the wheelbarrow over to our testing
station and start casting these
compressive cylinders every day we're
breaking these cylinders checking it for
strength you can see these have been
broken today this strength increases
over time so samples are tested at 7 14
and 28 days when the concrete is said to
have reached full strength so what we do
is we list the date that there will be
placed in the compression machine on top
of every cylinder in reality it will
continue strengthening after that
samples are placed in a hydraulic press
and then the pressure is increased on
them until they fail all right ready
yeah let's do it start loading sure we
want to maintain around 30 PSI per
second and it's important to load at
that rate yeah you don't want to shock
it you don't want to shock it by
applying too much load too fast this
middle number showing us our strength in
pounds per square inch and then the top
number the big number showing us the
force of pounds we're applying what are
we going to get up to like 7 000 PS 10
000 10 000. so this is going to be
really strong very strong okay yeah it's
always fun to get something
it'll shake this room of course concrete
walls
it's amazingly just like you can't see
anything happening
even under all that pressure
still holding
mm-hmm
over eleven thousand now
all right
yeah that's cool I like that like the
strongest Concrete in the world well the
strongest Concrete in the world is going
to be like a lab only thing and a
competition was up above a hundred
thousand PSI
today virtually all concrete is made
with a cement formulation discovered in
the 1840s it's known as Portland cement
but the name is really just a marketing
term you know they claimed that the gray
color of the cement would resemble these
very desirable rocks which were quarried
near the Town of Portland England but
the Portland cement was made by crushing
up Limestone and then mixing it with a
certain percentage of shale or clay to
provide the silicates and that was all
ground up into a fine powder and put in
a kiln and heated to very high
temperatures and what comes out are
these nodules that are really hard
they're called clinker now it's
suspected that cement Chemists in the
past may have produced clinker by
accident when they overcooked their lime
mixtures but since this clinker is so
hard to grind down they just considered
it waste but if you do grind it down the
cement that it produces is far superior
to basically any other chemistry we've
discovered which which is why it is so
commonly used today now there are lots
of compounds inside Portland cement the
most common one is tricalcium silicate
I'm now feeling incredibly buoyant
like I am now floating in concrete which
is pretty ridiculous because most of my
body is out of the material but because
it's three times as dense as water you
can float just up to your waist
this is totally unexpected I did not
expect to be able to like float and
concrete my feet are off the floor
that's where my feet are
my feet are here and my shoulders are up
and I'm just being pushed up out of this
once you have the cement powder the
other things you need to make concrete
are the Aggregates Sand and Gravel
these are blasted out of a quarry
then they're ground up to be particular
sizes they're very strict requirements
about the sizes and shapes of the
aggregate which is going to get poured
into the concrete because of course that
will affect the strength of the concrete
that results yeah this is a just a
well-graded concrete stand the most
well-rounded material helps the
contractor as far as their finish
ability goes yeah you know when they're
running that trowel over that slab they
want a rounded particle not a jagged
crushed particle do you really want like
a spherical sand around it yeah
spherical sand like a river stone like a
river sand
designers on the Strip want to pour
concrete elevated they want to lighten
up the load of the deck we'll
incorporate some lightweight aggregate
in place of this normal wheat
3 8 size typical concrete will weigh 150
pounds per cubic foot normal weight this
gets us about 110 pounds per cubic foot
oh
the Aggregates are hauled to the
concrete plant in big trucks all right
I'm gonna release The Rock
[Music]
where they're dumped
and then they travel on big conveyor
belts up into storage piles
these get loaded into big Hoppers and
then weighed out and poured into the
trucks the control operators Can Open
this gate and drop material into this
Hopper
down into the mixer truck below
this is where the batch operators
controlling the plant
right here in front of our batch
operator William is the actual recipe
that he's going to dispense into the
concrete mixer each line represents a
different component in the concrete that
top one there is a three-quarter Rock we
have an intermediate 3 8 rock below it
and there's your sand over here in this
column he's targeting for instance
three-quarter Rock he wants to hit 13
000 pounds of material for that load the
computer is going to try to hit 13 042
pounds of three-quarter Rock
so everything's everything filling up
right now
if he goes out of Tolerance and he
overshoots a Target it's going to change
to red a red color
up here on this screen we're actually
showing the holding Hopper this material
he's weighing is directly above the
mixer truck that just pulled under the
plant
what about the water William being
orange yeah we're a little under on that
but we can always add a little water
yeah we cannot take it away
all right I'm gonna take a look inside
the truck here
that's what it looks like down inside a
cement truck
so I was interested to see what would be
the difference in strength between pure
cement cement with sand and cement with
sand and gravel like the typical
concrete mix that they would make so I
had them make up these special cylinders
and test them in the hydraulic press you
might think that since pure cement has
the most glue it would be the strongest
cements the the magic right the glue so
if we lessen or lower the amount of
cement per unit volume we're going to
have less strength but when we tested
the pure cement cylinder it fractured a
lot as the load was applied
is that it no no let's let it keep going
it can take some more pressure what
8 000 PSI now it failed
now cement plus sand
[Applause]
9163 edit the prediction my prediction
was based on the strength it was two
weeks ago which we
we have here we got 14 days of six
thousand six hundred so you know reason
would be it'd probably break another
thousand PSI above that but it
definitely gained a lot and finally
cement plus sand and gravel this is the
normal concrete mix
is that it
that's it that's it
so it did fail at 8 300.
okay I was surprised to see that all the
cylinders broke under about the same
pressure I think to me really
interesting that you could have all of
that cement right but you don't get
appreciably right stronger than like
this or that cement is the most
expensive part of concrete so if you can
get away with reducing it down to 30 in
the mix and you still get the same
strength characteristics well then you
should definitely do that the other
thing that was interesting was pure
cement seemed to flake and Chip more as
it was loaded so it seemed like adding
the aggregate actually helped the sample
cohere and stay together even under all
that load
so was Roman concrete Superior to Modern
concrete well the answer is no in short
I mean there were some surprising
advantages that Roman concrete had for
example it was actually less well mixed
than modern concrete so there were
little blocks of undissolved calcium
oxide or quick lime that remained inside
Roman concrete and then what happened is
when the concrete cracked and water got
in there it would dissolve that calcium
oxide forming calcium hydroxide and then
you would get the new growth of calcium
carbonate so Roman concrete was actually
self-healing that's kind of a
fascinating advantage
but I would say by and large you know
when we look back at the Roman
structures we only see the ones that
have survived to this day so there is a
Survivor bias and finally there's the
issue of cost we could make very strong
concretes that could last an incredibly
long time but we choose not to because
it's just cheaper and we don't expect
our buildings to last that long
before the concrete goes out on site
they have to make sure it's the right
consistency for the customer not too dry
and not too runny this can be adjusted
with water but you don't really want to
do that because that can also affect the
strength so here they use modern
chemicals like super plasticizers so up
here on the top left you have our
dispensing units for all our chemical
admixtures and that's what they're
adding now of super plasticizer it makes
the concrete easier to work and spread
around without really changing the water
content very much
to check that the consistency is right
they perform something called a slump
test or spread test we're going to fill
the cone to the top
nice and level
and we're going to pull that metal cone
off
measure the distance it travels on the
board the concrete they're pouring on me
should have a spread of 27 inches
we're going to measure it both sides
right on the 27 on that one yeah then go
this way
right on a 27 on that one
so why is it so important you got the
right consistency of concrete you don't
want it too dry you want it wet enough
to flow and and fill up whatever
container you're trying to fill in this
case the sphere
with you in it so the question you're
probably wondering is how long can I
stay in here before the concrete hardens
the usual answer is about four hours
without agitation and that's why when
you see concrete trucks driving down the
road that drum has to be turning to keep
the concrete agitated and prevent it
from setting up but what happens if the
truck breaks down or there's a traffic
jam or something breaks then at times
concrete does Harden inside the drum of
these trucks and that is a terrible
outcome but there is one thing you can
do to slow the concrete down from
setting and that is to add some regular
pop like Coke
the sugars inside this coke actually
prevent the setting up process from
happening and that can buy you a few
hours so apparently these truck drivers
they drive around with a few two liter
bottles of pop inside their cab and so
they can dump it in their load if they
have to to prevent it from setting up so
hopefully that means I'll get out okay
too
but how does concrete actually Harden
well you have the dry mixture of gravel
sand and cement powder and then you add
water the water starts dissolving the
cement powder grains so ions enter
solution and some of those ions are
calcium hydroxide so that's what makes
concrete a very basic solution
what do you see we're approaching 12
11.8 so the pH of concrete can get up to
12 or 13 the pH of this is 11.8 and
that's incredibly basic which means if
it's on your skin if it's on your body
it can be dissolving your skin and in
cells being buried in concrete is sort
of like jumping in a vat of bleach and
that's why I'm actually wearing a dry
suit and some latex gloves yeah it's not
something you want to try at home so do
not try swimming in concrete
so now the ions are dissolved in the
solution and remember the most common
compound in cement is tricalcium
silicate as it reacts with the water
crystals start to form of calcium
silicate hydrates plus other hydrate
minerals and all these crystals grow and
become interlocking causing the concrete
to harden note that the water is
essential to the formation of these
crystals so water is not evaporating
it's not drying out it's actually
becoming part of the solid concrete
material and that's why this chemistry
is called cement hydration is also why
freshly poured concrete should be kept
in as damp an environment as possible
Las Vegas is so dry they frequently set
up misters to spray around new concrete
to ensure the humidity was high enough
one of the things I realized while
making this video is that Limestone the
core component of cement and concrete
well it comes from ancient sea life
limestone is formed from the skeletons
and shells of ancient sea organisms that
you know died millions of years ago and
then all of that got compressed and now
we use that to make huge skyscrapers and
you know overpasses basically every huge
piece of infrastructure it's made with
concrete and so now when you look at a
beautiful city skyline what you're
really seeing is ancient marine life
skyscrapers are made of seashells
[Music]
yeah this is mild this is hilarious I
like I have no words I'm like trying to
push myself down into it but it's like
it pushes me up like I'm pushing down
into the concrete but it's like well I'm
getting pushed out of this thing I'm
just gonna try to push myself down in
here
like that is it there is no you cannot
get buried in concrete okay I'm doing my
best right now to like sink down and it
is not happening but I'm going to use my
arms to to push myself in
oh
working against buoyancy this is hard
we were worried about getting me out but
like I can't stay in I'm gonna try to
jump in here we go
that's it all right here we go one two
three
that's great
oh
[Music]
that feels so good
I like don't want to get out this is uh
so nice does anyone got a time check
this stuff is not going to set up on me
is it
so as we've seen concrete is one of the
most important materials in the world
it's made possible most of the
large-scale infrastructure we rely on
but it also creates a lot of CO2 an
estimated eight percent of the global
total that is more than the entire
Aviation sector but together we can do
something about that I would personally
like to offset one month of your carbon
emissions and I will do that through
this video sponsor Ren Ren is a website
where you can calculate your carbon
footprint see which aspects of your
lifestyle make the biggest contribution
and learn how to reduce your impact and
then if you like you can offset your
carbon footprint by finding a diverse
mix of carbon reduction projects like
tree planting mineral weathering and
reinforced protection for the first
hundred people to sign up I will
personally offset your first month of
emissions just click on the link in the
description now I don't think we're
going to solve climate change using
individual action alone if you can
change your light bulbs or install solar
that is great but what we really need is
change on a systemic scale and that's
what I like about Ren's approach they
not only plant trees and protect
rainforests they also support policy
groups lobbying for change like the
clean air task force which advocates for
new technologies and policies to get to
a zero emissions economy the way I see
it there are moneyed interests lobbying
to keep things the way they are so we
need to band together through
organizations like Ren to lobby for
Change and if you agree with me then I
invite you to click the link in the
description and join me in offsetting
our carbon emissions and investing in
large-scale systemic change so I want to
thank Ren for sponsoring veritasium and
I want to thank you for watching